hey everyone in this video we'll be
doing a side-by-side comparison of the
original skyward sword to its brand new
hd remaster with footage i captured of
both
a few things to note before we begin the
original version of skyward sword is a
wii game but the capture used in this
video is the wii version running on a
wii u and captured a 1080p
so it's the original standard definition
image quality blown up
and the hd version is captured on switch
at 1080p
also the wii version is running at 30
frames per second while the new hd
remaster runs at 60 frames per second so
you'll notice one is smoother than the
other
and lastly the new switch version is
being played with button controls
if you like this video and want to see
more comparisons like it then consider
subscribing to gamespot
so without further ado let's hop on our
loft wings and go for a ride
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
huh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
hello
thanks for watching if you like this
video then consider dropping a like it
helps us more than you think
if you're interested in seeing more
skyward sword hd videos we have 10
minutes of gameplay on our second
channel
a live stream i did with kurt and divina
a video about the biggest changes
between the two
and our video review all going up within
the next few days if they're not up
already
links to all of those can be found in
the description for everything zelda
stay tuned to gamespot
[Music]
you